[MUSIC]
The greatest coach in the history of
professional sports Sir Alex Ferguson.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You're looking very dapper tonight.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> My mother looks after me well.
>> [LAUGH] Looks like we're the only
two who got dressed this evening.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So what would you do, Sir Alex,
if some of this scruffy
mob here showed up and
were players, and
wanted to get on the Majesty United bus?
>> Well, first I was a coach, everyone
had to have a short haircut, all shaven.
I don't know how managers allow players on
the bus with a beard, that's not for me.
>> Mm-hm.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now, whether
If I've not lost my strength,
if I would allow that.
But what I did like to see was my team
coming to a ground with the United
blazer on, white shirt and a tie because
they're representing Manchester United.
>> And what would you do if
they didn't show up like that?
>> Well, I think it's part of
the education you have to give them.
The responsibility they have as
an Manchester United player.
And it's just a discipline.
And I think that was
a strong disciplined United.
And it's still today.
Even Louis van Gaal, all smart,
I know it's a the boys that are not
playing sit in the back of the director's
box, blazer and flannels on, I like that.
That's for me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm sorry you guys with the beards.
>> You recommend a shave, would you?
So did you see the game on Saturday?
The Everton game.
>> Yep. Yep. >> What'd you think?
>> Did very well.
I thought it was going to be
a difficult game actually, and
I saw Everton did all
the strongest team out.
You know, and I thought this is going to
be a difficult game because the last I
think they've lost the last three years
there, but they won very comfortably.
Complete control, the way they
change the system a little bit.
I thought Evan couldn't handle it.
So, I was pleased, because after,
the great test of any Manchester United
team is how you recover after defeats.
There was three-nil with Arsenal,
a bad defeat.
They come out at the next game, win.
And that's the best way
to answer the critics and
also to show the resolve and
the determination to get over a defeat.
Because it's not easy at Club United.
When you lose you're front page,
when you win you're back page.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a difference.
>> Better to be on the back page.
So, there are, I think if I counted
correctly, there were 8 of the 18
players who showed up,
who were in the squad on Saturday.
Were players that you had signed.
How long does it take to knit everybody
else together into a really cohesive unit?
Is that a matter of years or
can you do it in a season?
>> Well, if you're talking with
the present court of players
>> And five last season, five this year,
and that's difficult.
Particularly, the players they brought
in were players from other countries.
The division's very difficult,
really difficult.
When we brought players in from abroad,
we always gave them first season,
forget it, second season, okay.
But one or two excelled, surprised us
by doing really well at the beginning.
In my time,
the thing that was different from me and
Louis Van Gaal of course
is that I had longevity.
I was there 27 years.
So when I went to United at first,
my job was to build the foundation
at that football club.
Because I think most managers,
quite rightly, have to think about
a football team, the first team because
as a result industry they are to
make sure the first team does well.
I never thought that way.
I thought that rebuilding the youth in the
club so they would give me a foundation
and I'd given them with the young
players coming through.
My conviction was never going to change.
I told the directors on day one,
that's exactly what I was going to do.
And of course, yeah,
I was concerned that the first team
[INAUDIBLE] second bout of the week.
And I just took my time with that,
I wasn't in a hurry, most concentration
was on scouting, trialing, and
coaching for the young people.
>> Mm hm.
Now at the end of the Everton game,
United are in third position
in English Premier League.
It's the end of October and
obviously everybody here is connected to
the business school in one way or another.
And an important thing in
business is setting expectations.
And how would you,
were you managing United today,
knowing that there's a long part
of the season still to come?
You still gotta play Christmas,
you gotta get, you're in the other
different cups and championships.
How do you go about setting
the expectation of where you would want
the club to wind up the end of the season
knowing your in third position today.
>> Well I think the definition,
you take my job Aberdeen.
Aberdeen's an awful Scotland.
Cut off from the central bell with
a mean stream of footballers.
I had to build an expectation,
to create an expectation for the players.
Whereas in United you have to
live with the expectations for
every player that comes through that club.
Even after Saturday's game,
every player on that team has
to weather the expectation.
So, the expectation is to win.
Absolute, whether it's a European cup or
a cup.
They all have to win.
That's the mentality they have.
The mindset is the winning mindset.
There's no question about that.
So, I never said to the press, we've got
to win the European cup, we've got to the.
I've never said that.
Every time at press conference,
well, I hope we win something.
I wouldn't want to get carried away and
give them a headline.
But, deep down, win every game.
That was the mentality.
I never expected to lose a game, ever.
>> Mm-hm.
Would you be talking to the players at
this juncture about the possibility of
winning the league this year?
>> No.
>> And when would you start privately
calculating whether or not you thought.
>> You won't believe this if I tell you.
Every begin of January.
I used to get all opponents games and
predict the point that we
want to get against us.
And I was never far wrong.
Never far wrong.
Even to the point that,
I knew we'd maybe have to make three
points up on one of our main opponents.
I was pretty accurate in that.
And I did this every year.
And so that, add my win.
Sort of a challenge.
>> Would you sit down with each of
the top clubs or the whole league?
>> Just the top clubs, only the four ones.
I will know by January 1st who our
main challenges are going to be.
And then I used to do that, I kept to
myself, I didn't share it with anyone.
I was never far wrong, That's good.
>> I knew even the years we lost it.
I knew that dangers we had
in terms of challenges.
>> You're pretty accurate about,
say in January, about the number of points
that United itself would have
at the end of the season.
>> Yeah.
>> Let me change the topic a little bit,
to two things that again are germane
to every sort of business.
One is assessing and judging talents and
another is discipline.
So, let me take you back.
It's 1957.
There is a young man growing sideburns.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Alex Ferguson who's
turning out in his first seasons for
a club in Scotland in
Glasgow called Queen's Park.
How would you assess
the talent of that player?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, outstanding comes to mind.
>> But, well, I probably
was one of the few players that played for
Glasgow Skills, Scotland Skills,
Scotland Youth, Scottish Amateur,
and the full Scottish team.
But I wasn't an outstanding player,
I was a goal scorer.
In fact, at United we used to get into
the video analysis room most mornings.
And this morning our Goalkeeping
coach Eric Steele says,
I was just pulling up
your goalscoring record.
He said that's pretty good, that.
179 goals in 300 games or
something like that.
And I said, that's only league goals,
I said where are my cup goals?
So, I said, well,
I'll try and get them out.
We couldn't get them.
We couldn't find any cup goals.
I don't know why, but
No, I was a goal scorer,
and had a great career without
actually winning anything.
I went to Rangers about the time when
Celtic were completely dominant.
They'd just won the European Cup
under Jock Stein, and
they were the fantastic team.
The were a devil to beat at that time.
But I enjoyed it, I had a good career.
The thing about playing is that
that is the best time of your life,
which relates to how I would never ask any
of my players to retire to become a coach.
I encouraged them to take their badges.
When I went to fulltime at football,
because I was an engineer.
I was a tool maker until I was 22,
was part-time at football.
I made my mind up.
I was not going back to Engineering.
So I took all my coaching badges,
I prepared to stay in the game.
Like everyone should do,
if you want to do something, prepare.
Whether it's through study, or
like I did, take your coaching badges,
I think that's an important issue.
>> And how well behaved on the field
was that young player Alex Ferguson?
>> You're getting this from my son Jason.
Had a bad record.
>> Pardon?
>> Had a bad record.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was sent off eight times
>> Pardon?
>> I know, I know.
But I was misunderstood.
[LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> Do you remember some
of the incidents about
why you were sent off?
>> Every one of them.
Yeah.
Retaliation was mostly.
Or maybe a late tackle or
something, or an elbow in someone's jaw or
something like that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I had a funny running style.
I run with my elbows like this.
So, I was always getting into trouble.
[LAUGH] Matt's laughing here.
I was always getting into trouble
because of my elbows, yeah.
>> The elbows.
>> Yeah.
So let's talk about judging other
talent several decades later.
I'm going to pick two players,
David Beckham and
another one we'll come to in a moment.
So, how did you first come across
Beckham and how old was he?
And what did he seem like as
a player when you first saw him?
>> Well, David came to know
us through a scout in London,
from the same area as David.
He was a headmaster at school,
Malcolm Fidgen.
And he put David on the radar, but
the real impact came from Bobby Charlton.
Bobby had soccer schools at the time,
and David had won a placement for
Bobby's soccer school in Barcelona.
And Bobby came back and
said I've seen a kid, you need.
So I flagged it up with the chief scout.
He said, of course,
he's coming next month.
Just by coincidence.
And that was a start, he would be
eleven years of age at the time.
He was a little thin boy,
he had no height, no physique whatsoever.
But he had this wonderful talent,
in terms of control of the ball,
striking the ball was really his forte.
And, his parents were United fans.
His grandfather was a Tottenham fan, but
he and his parents were United fans.
So he used to come to the game.
After we got the contact with him,
we invited him to the games
every time we were in London.
And, in fact,
he was a a ball boy in the West Ham
game which is this area of London.
And he was a certainty to come to United.
He trained at Tottenham for a while.
I think he trained somewhere else,
maybe Fulham or something like that.
But he was always destined
to come to United because he
wanted to come to United.
And, in that class of 92, who were
the team to win the Youth Cup, David never
got on the team until the semi-finals
because he was just a little boy.
Then, within months,
[SOUND] six foot, still thin,
no confirmation in his body whatsoever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, he was a skinny boy.
>> And then,
That group with the same desires,
the seven or
eight of them, they talk about
the ones that are well known,
Giggs, Scholes, Butt,
the two Nevilles and David.
But we had two other players would've been
great players, but their careers were cut
by injury, Chris Casper and
Ben Thornley, they were outstanding.
But they all practiced.
>> Give a sense of how
hard these guys worked.
>> Well, the training would
start 10 o'clock to 12 o'clock.
The other ones, they would be out in
the afternoon practicing all the time, or
with the youth coach in terms
of their general training.
And for David, who lived in accommodation
with Mrs. Gosling with several other boys,
he would go into the school of at
nighttime and help the coaches.
With the young kids.
So his desires were strong, and
also he was a practicer, he'd practice,
practice, practice.
And I think that the advice
I'd give to any young kid is,
anyone can play a game of football,
anyone.
But practice makes you a real footballer.
You see games on a Sunday.
Pub games.
Oh, love a game of football.
The real players had
a practice ethic about them.
I remember being at lunch in Glasgow many,
many years ago,
and Gary Player was the guest.
>> The golfer?
>> The golfer.
And they asked him that question, why
do you keep practicing from the bunker?
Because he was famous for,
you know, the bunkers.
I know, I'm going to be in
the bunker at one time in the game,
maybe twice in the game, and
I've got to put it in the hole.
That's why I practiced, and
practiced, and practiced.
That's a great example of what you
have to do to be a top player.
And David and
all these young lads did that same.
And all the young kids
at United practice well.
>> Different Well known
name Christiano Ronaldo,
how old was he when you
first came across him?
>> 17 he was.
>> And
how did he first tip your radar screen?
>> That's a great story because my
assistant, of course is a Portuguese.
And he thought it'd be a good idea for
us to have an association,
a relationship with the sport in Lisbon,
because he'd been there as a kid, and
he was from Lisbon.
And he set it up, and what we're
doing then was sharing coaching.
So we would send coaches over there,
and they would send coaches to us.
And Jim Ryan, who was head of youth
department at the time, youth scouting.
He came back, he says,
well I've seen a player.
And he was playing center for
youth team at the time.
So I says to it would be a good idea if
maybe we'd build a relationship here.
And he spoke to the president,
and the deal was
that we couldn't get him the next year,
but we could get them two years from then.
Then [INAUDIBLE] left me the next year,
we'd promised
through the association with him, the
relationship, we'd offer the new stadium.
>> This is at Sporting [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Yeah, Sporting, that's correct.
And we flew from the States, from here,
to Lisbon and played the game.
And Christiano's playing outside
left against John O'Shea,
and the poor soul's got tortured blood.
Honestly, he is absolutely annihilated.
And I'm up there going, John!
Get up and get some.
He says, I can't.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I get my kit manager.
I says,
go up there to the directors box and
get Peter Kenyon down
right away at half time.
So Peter Kenyon comes down.
I says, we're not leaving here.
>> Peter Kenyon was the then-
>> Chief executive.
>> Chief executive of United.
>> At that time, yeah.
And I says, we're not going to go and
wave in here that you're playing.
So then we got a little room after
the game with the president of Lisbon,
his agent, his lawyer and the boy.
I said I want you to come
back with us to Manchester.
Now that's a test.
If he doesn't want to come,
you know he doesn't want to join you.
He says, yeah I'd love to come but
I want my mother.
>> Yeah.
>> So I said, great.
Next morning his mother, his sister,
his brother, the whole trip come out.
And I said to him, I promise you
one thing, you'll get the best
education you could possibly get here,
but you won't play every week.
And he looked at him that.
He was impressed.
He didn't expect that.
I says, the Premier League's
a very difficult league
and you may play substitute sometime,
you play an odd game,
you may in the League Cup which we
do have a lot of young players.
And, he said, but
when do I get in the first team?
Well, if you get to a level that's
Manchester United, I can't stop you.
You pick yourself.
And he played his first game, he was sub
in the first game of the season against
Bolton and he came on at half time and
the crowd went absolute mad with them.
He was absolutely fantastic.
He had courage to take the ball,
the first rate back of
first minute, he come on the second half,
he got them and says, give me the ball.
And the great players
have gotten this courage.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Nothing will daunt them.
>> They're not afraid of anything.
And Christiano had that.
>> And how,
when he first came to Manchester,
I think he came with his mother and
his mother's sister.
>> Yeah, yeah.
How disciplined was he in his sort
of daily ritual at that point?
>> He was the best
practicer I've ever known.
But he had these what you would
call Latin American faults.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You can get arrested for
saying that in the state of California.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it's a simple fault,
which can be eradicated, if the boy's
got the right desire and discipline.
And listen to us.
And he was diving as a young kid.
>> Diving to try and get a penalty.
>> Yeah correct.
The players were great with him.
Every time he'd go down and scream, the
players would go an scream at him back.
Get up you, and all that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I used to get at him all the time.
And the unfortunate thing for Ronaldo
because he was such a great player.
The press never left him alone in that
situation because After about a year,
year and a half, it never happened.
But any time we've failed,
someone all knowing and
curious will say, oh yeah, he dives.
But no, it's not true, because [INAUDIBLE]
against defenders, all you need
to do is nudge him a little bit and
the [INAUDIBLE] scores and they go down.
But it wasn't, [INAUDIBLE].
>> Did the criticism get to him at all?
>> No no.
I remember he come off of that period,
at the season [INAUDIBLE]
off,
and he said he wasn't going to come back.
And I flew out to Portugal and I said
look, he wanted to go to Real Madrid.
It was always his lifetime
ambition to do that.
And I said, look, you give me a year and
you go on with my blessing to Real Madrid.
He was fantastic.
But the first game was at Charlton.
And I sat in the director's box, and
there's this guy down in front of me.
He's up and he's giving them so
much, the cursing, the language.
Then about five minutes from the half
time, he got the ball, he beat three men,
cut in, hit the underside of the bar.
The guy never got up again.
That wasn't finished.
He had the courage to do all that.
>> And Christiano today,
considerable many years later now,
does he still have the same
sort of drive and work ethic?
>> I've never known anyone like him,
honestly.
I was at his house for
dinner a few month ago.
And his services made for the best player
in the world, no doubt about that.
>> How's that?
>> The gymnasium's probably about half
the the size of this, this size here.
He's got everything in it.
He's got two pools,
he's got a hot pool and a cold pool.
He's got an atrium at minus 160 degrees.
He goes in there for
ten minutes after every game.
It's just unbelievable.
And I says to him, he says to me,
I'm going to retire at 35.
I said you don't retire at 35.
You can play til you're 40, easily.
Ryan Giggs has played to 41.
Says no, no, I'm doing that, and
I'm working on making sure I'm
three kilograms under my best
weight the last five years.
But I went, brilliant.
>> Right.
>> Amazing.
Now, with all these people,
with all players of incredible caliber,
Eckermann, Aldove,
the others that you had, how do,
what were the tools that you
used to maintain discipline?
>> Well, I think that the most important
thing is to be consistent, who you are and
don't change.
And I never changed, I didn't use
discipline as a weapon against players.
They would be disciplined if they
stepped out of line for certain reasons,
maybe a silly sending off or
a misbehaving outside the ground.
But I never used it as
a continual weapon against them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You got disciplined.
It's over.
We move on.
And they all accept that, eventually.
They.
They understand who you are.
That's the most important thing, because
that's the essence of being a leader.
They know who you are.
You're consistent,
they trust that you're right, and
this one is an important aspect of
managing them, there's no question.
But technically, you're dealing
with very well paid players.
If you've got a discipline that's
different with different people,
you're going to wrong way.
So, my dicipline is always the same for
everyone.
I never treated anyone any different.
>> And what was the sort of
discipline that the players dreaded?
Was it the fine, or
the threat of being transferred or
being put in the stands to watch a game.
>> I think every player wants to play in.
Even though we had no indication of it,
disappointed player by
being in the stands.
But the other aspect of
putting players in the stands
is because you have a score to 24.
And you have to pick 1 11.
Now that's difficult.
But what I used to do was,
because my own experience as a player,
I was told 50 minutes from a kick-off in
the Scottish Cup final I wasn't playing.
I was the top goalscorer and
there was no subs at the time.
So that was always in my mind about how
to treat players if they're not playing.
So I used to call them in,
individual with all of them, and
explain to them why they weren't playing.
It was very easy as time went on
because they knew with a squad of 24,
it's not the 11 that win the league, it's
the 24 that win the league or the cup.
No question about that.
And the important part to do that is to
trust them to whatever team you play.
And make them feel that
they have contributed
like the best players in winning.
>> And Sir Alex, how did you ensure
that even for the bigger stars they all
understood that they were part of,
not the, but part of a team?
>> Well I think the best players,
the ones that want to win more.
The best players who've got that ego,
a win is important to them.
So I enjoyed that.
I enjoyed players with that confidence.
>> But how did you make sure that none
of them began to think that they were
bigger than United in themselves?
>> Well the message is,
to prove they're the best,
they have to work as hard as everyone
else and even more than other ones.
And that was the best
you'd always give to them.
The evidence is always
on the football field.
The best player can let themselves down,
by not living up to expectation,
his own expectation in fact.
[SOUND] Oops!
That's gone.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I had no great worries with that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The fight had been there such
a long time of course helps, but
also I think that players who come to
United, that club is such a great club.
They don't want to miss the bus.
They want to go on the bus all the time.
And I think that was very important.
>> Now, how do you, let's switch the topic
a little bit and talk about compensations.
Some of these players are getting paid
a large amount of money, obviously.
How do managers cope?
Not you, because you were among the
highest compensated in the Premier League.
But there are some clubs where the
managers are paid less than their players.
How do they ever have a chance of
establishing authority in those clubs?
>> I think in most cases I was maybe a
little bit different because I always felt
that being the manager of
Manchester United I should be the highest
paid person.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah but
it's important because the responsibility
of managing that club is huge.
I'm there more hours than any of them.
I've got the biggest responsibility.
So I feel that should
be always recognized.
Not always years, by the way.
Took a long time to agree with me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
I think from other managers' point of
view, I think they expect that the very,
very top player is going to be paid more.
I have no issue at all with what
players get paid, the top players.
You know why?
I think if you look at golfers.
>> For sure.
>> American footballers,
basketball players.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Head funded masters.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, exactly.
Or potentially your
wealthy old men are there.
But then, I have no issue with that
because they're bringing 75,000 people
when they all effort.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What about saying good bye to players,
whether they were 16, 17,
18 year olds you didn't
think were going to make it?
And then let's talk about them and then I
wanted to talk about some of the players
who'd done well by you that
you had to say good bye to.
What about that case?
>> Well the most difficult task for
any manager is telling a young kid
he's not going to make it United.
When we bring a boy to the club,
we speak to the parents and
we say, we always say the same.
We hope your boy plays in front
of 75,000 people, if not,
we're confident we can get
him a career in the game.
Even to this day,
there will be about 90 players in England,
Scotland, Germany all started
a career as a Manchester native.
And that's been like that for
10 to 15 years.
Very difficult to tell them that.
I did this stupid thing where
something as a young coach.
I was filmed.
I was terrified to tell a young boy he was
not you know, going to be good enough.
So I had this idea bring
the five of them in.
>> Five young boys together?
>> And I told them.
One of them started crying.
Oh I never.
That was that.
Finished.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It was a difficult time.
It was not easy.
>> And what about some of the older
players who had done very well by you and
then you had to break the news
to them that they were done?
>> That's equally hard because you
know I'd become a father to them, and
it's such a family business
[INAUDIBLE] anyway that.
For instance a team on 94 worked
with us for quite a few years.
>From round about 91, right through to the
1967, with Dennis Ober and Steve Bruce.
Brian Robson, Gar Powester.
And they'd love to play to the 90.
But they don't actually
realize they get older.
I'm the one that recognizes it because
I see it on the football field.
But what I did with them,
was made sure we give them free transfers.
So they made the free bob, Dennis went
to Steve Bruce went to Birmingham.
Bryan Robson actually became
a manager at Middlesbrough.
And Gary Paulsen went back
to Middlesbrough with him.
So [INAUDIBLE] with Paul Parker.
We gave him a free transfer.
[INAUDIBLE] A free transfer.
They've got clubs, West Brom.
Paul went to Fulham.
So, we did well by them.
And recognition for the service they give
us, and I think that was real important.
Money doesn't come into it when
the guy's giving you ten years.
So I think it's the best
way you could do it.
And the only thing you can do,
and it definitely works,
is to be honest with them.
That's the only thing that works.
You don't want to go take these guys on.
>> Right.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Professionals,
who have been great to you.
>> Different topic.
What about, again, for a lot of people
setting out on lives in management and
everything.
What are some of the things that you
wished you had known when you were 30 or
32, just setting off on your lifetime
of management up in Scotland?
>> Yeah.
I got this at Harvard.
This is I belted the question,
had to think about it for a while.
And the easiest one I think
about is communication,
recognition, absolutely vital.
When I was 32, I wanted to rule the world.
I was a young manager at Most
players are playing at 32, but
I had a groin injury and
I gave up to go into management.
>> It wasn't the elbows that were?
>> No, there was, they were polished.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I was holding the grass feed for
the groundsmen, and pies for
the the director's room.
The programs on Saturday.
And, you know,
you forget to manage up the way.
When the chairmen went to go full time,
you know when that became-
>> Mmhmmm, right.
Right.
>> I didn't realize I still
carried on the way I did.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Of course he can sack you.
Which he did for a [CROSSTALK]
>> So let's talk about the two things.
One, how did you learn to delegate?
>> I think,
the natural thing about delegation was,
I wasn't properly recognizing
until I got to about maybe 60.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then I realized, is well,
if I'm going to keep my energy,
I've got to do it.
And then you have to
give the trust to that.
By that time anyway I
trusted all my staff anyway.
It was just a natural thing
that when you've got energy and
you've done something for so long,
you don't think it's ever going to change.
But, of course, age changes you.
And then I delegated far better.
I delegated a lot actually after that.
The thing of it energy and anyone
listening to this, is very important.
When you stop, where you've add to the
united, we'll see at 43, 44 years of age.
The seething energy, the pure seething
energy, you see it burns over you.
But when you get to the 60s,
they still expect to see it.
>> Mh-hm.
>> So I had to look at myself in
terms of energy, that I was a select.
because when I was a young manager,
four or five years, no problem.
When I got to my 60s,
I needed six or seven hours.
So you go to bed earlier.
You work at your diet better,
after the game at home.
I never, very very seldom and ate.
So that added examine myself of my energy
because people want to see the energy.
A very important aspect to it, you know?
>> Yeah, the second aspect of that
was what you just alluded to, during,
coming a cropper with an owner.
>> Yeah.
>> What's the advice you give managers
these days these days when they call
you about the relationship that
they should have with the owner of
the club that they work for?
>> You've got to find a way.
It doesn't matter what you think of them.
You've got to find out whether that
can be a good harmony, going together.
And also to agree that you're
both going the same direction.
I think that, even if you find a way
of actually getting on with them, and
they're going that way and you're
going that way, it still doesn't work.
So you have to find out
that we have agreed
were the direction the club is going,
and the job you're doing.
Now that I think of it, reckon it's
communication, is a really important part
too, that you must recognize
that people are working for you.
Knowing their names, saying good
morning to them in the morning.
I had a manager, as a player,
he couldn't say good morning to you.
He'd walk by you.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Now that cold be racket conference,
could be anything.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But you have to recognize
that people work for you.
>> Right, right.
>> And every time you win a cup or
trophy, every man by that staff or
in that canteen.
The laundry girls, the canteen staff,
the groundsman, the champion out,
because to see a trophy as much as
the players, they became a team that way.
>> Now,
did you enjoy the celebrations yourself?
>> No, no no.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because any game lasts for
me about half an hour.
And I'm thinking about tomorrow.
And I was just-
>> Even after 1999,
the famous treble season?
>> After the dinner I went to bed.
After the club, I went to my bed.
>> Do you wake the next
morning in a bad mood, or?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was exhausted.
Actually, when the team are getting
presented with the cup I went for a walk.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the bus one has all these alleys
and little corridors and all of this and
I'm walking through them all and bump
into this friend of mine from Aberdeen.
He couldn't take either.
He was wanting the,
heard from the manager.
And we're working through
all these alleys,
and then we see this buggy coming up.
And it's a guy who's looking for
me, he says,
you gotta go to the press conference.
This is about half an hour after the game.
I can celebrate for half an hour,
then it was [INAUDIBLE].
>> Right,
how did you avoid complacency and
getting complacent and-
>> Well it's a disease you know.
Every time at half time if we win a game
has come up, it comes up all the time.
you know there's nothing you can do
about it when you get complacent.
I mean a few occasions its never one
in the same connect with United because
their human beings but we kept reminding
them when half the time your willing.
Complacency, It's a disease.
The Ryder Cup.
This is the message I gave to the team
in the Ryder Cup that were in Europe-
>> The British team?
>> Yeah.
And, I told them, I said you think
about Medinah two years before.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, the ten-six on a Saturday night.
They're winning ten-six, America.
And I'm sitting there in the dinner.
And they're promising each other,
when we win these four and a half points.
There's a great temptation there,
isn't it, of some type.
Win four and a half points.
And the coincidence resonated later.
And, but, you don't win the first point.
And he win the second point, and
then there's [INAUDIBLE] bit confusion.
Then win the third point,
panic, and then capitulation.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Unfortunately, with that message,
put Europe [INAUDIBLE] west game,
10 six in front.
Fantastic.
>> Yep.
>> It's a disease.
We were playing Everton.
We lost the league because of it.
Four to two, seven minutes to go.
We lost two goals.
And that causes a weak and
their human beings,
the best way to keep reminding them.
That complacency could cost everything.
And there's no way out
when complacency sets in.
There is no way out.
Absolutely no way out.
>> One other question from me and then
I know we have some audience questions.
You had this incredible
record that's unparalleled.
Did you ever feel, or
do you feel that you should have won more?
>> Absolutely.
I do honestly.
I think that European cups
was my biggest regret.
And on some occasion were very unlucky.
Some occasions where we got
bad decisions against us and
some occasions we didn't play well enough.
>> Mm hm.
>> And the three semi-finals we lost and
the two were against Dortmund in '97 And
against in 2001.
We should have won those games.
>> Does that still bother you today?
>> Yeah, it does.
I don't think you should
ever look back with regrets.
But when you ask a question,
that it bothers me all the time,
and so I, but I have no bitterness
about it cause football,
I can't work in my career and
[INAUDIBLE] and regret anything.
I had a fantastic time, but
the question is, the way you put it to me,
yes we should have won more
European championships.
Our last season playing
Real Madrid [INAUDIBLE] referee.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What do you really think of him?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
Absolutely control the game.
And there wasn't a player at that time,
it's ten minutes to get over and
by that time they scored two goals.
And even at two to one down,
was that we made all the chances.
So, It's a disappointment,
but, as I say, I can't [INAUDIBLE]
I had.
>> Let me welcome Nev Given.
She has I know a few
questions from the audience.
And how many people here are soccer
players in the audience.
[COUGH] Good.
>> Not bad.
>> And NCAA soccer players?
Fantastic.
>> I'm going to take the liberty
of asking the first question.
So, you touched on aspects earlier but
here in the valley our equivalent of the
prize footballers are the best engineers.
They're paid the most, they get
poached by rival tech companies, yet
most of us at the GSB are most
likely to go in as their managers.
For the early days,
what are you top tips to garner their
respect despite the fact that were
not techie, retain control and
ensure that no individual becomes larger
than the team or the organization.
>> We're dealing with
players who are mega-stars or
players with egos and are wealthy.
I honestly believe that those people
are genuinely the winners all the time.
That's why they go there
in the first place.
And yeah, there'll be occasions
where they slip off the platform
of where they were and
maybe get complacent, whatever.
But it's easy to remind
someone who's a winner.
It's easy to remind them
how they got there.
What was their expectation.
I think it's important
to remind them of that.
They represent themselves in a big way,
and
I think that should always
be reminded of them.
>> What management trait did you
not have that you wish you had and
how did you compensate for that?
>> Languages, definitely languages.
Because when United changed, when
the academy system come into being and
we had to change the The dynamics
of the club in terms of scouting.
Then more Europeans players come in,
from South America,
from France, [INAUDIBLE] to Spain,
whatever, Germany.
One year, particularly,
there were 21 nationalities in the club.
Now, I had French and German at school.
But, it's like, when you leave school and
you don't use the languages,
you forget about them.
So when we start to get, I start
thinking about how I could communicate,
particularly with the French players.
And it's not easy.
Languages is really important.
I said to my son Mark,
I said years ago when he was in school,
is another one that went, he was just I'm
going to do this, I'm going to do that.
[INAUDIBLE],
20 years later.
It's really important to communicate
with players in their own language.
That's why I brought and
spoke four, five language.
Fantastic because we had
all these nationalities and
the communication was easy then.
Carlos would do all that.
And I would do my little
smatterings in French.
We only had one German player, a young
boy, Ronny Zieler who's with Hannover now.
He was the only one I needed
to communicate with in German.
I think that is important, languages.
>> I sympathize with it.
I've barely mastered english.
I am surprised that weren't more
tweets coming through for racing or
wine tips from you, seeing that your
track record on that is as good as many.
>> Forget the racing tips.
>> I sadly, and
the audience are going to to kill me, but
we've only got two minutes left.
So, I'm going to ask a question which,
to you both actually,
which is somewhat synonymous with the GSB,
because it's one that we will have to
answer as part of our applications.
And that is, what matters most and why?
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's a good question.
>> Yeah.
>> Why, I think your upbringing.
I think my upbringing was fantastic.
I had parents who give me good
disciplines, good advice.
Don't be late, don't cheat,
don't steal, don't lie.
These things stood by me all my life.
And I hope, then,
that foundation I bring to me kids, and
you can bring it to their kids.
And that's what I'm bringing is,
it's an inheritance.
That's what it is, and
I think that was important to me.
>> Best family heirloom.
Sir Michael?
>> Following your instincts.
>> Short and sweet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, with that,
please join me in thanking Sir Michael and
Sir Alex.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well done.
[MUSIC]